flat
beautiful hi we're the dimelios and we
are playing Drew's reality check where
we read rumors about us from the
internet and tell you if they're true or
not you're so close to me and stick
around after for Rapid Fire q a
[Music]
rumor number one Charlie and Dixie's
parents force them to make Tick-Tock
videos that is no not true okay
yeah you can't force me to do anything
if honestly if they were I don't live
with them anymore so I could just turn
my phone off I cannot care less if they
do tick tocks or not but we do force
them to make Tick Tock they do they do
she'll like get in my Tick Tock I'm like
I posted dad rumor number two Charlie
and Dixie compete against each other we
have a competition show on Snapchat so
technically we do compete against each
other but in everyday life no never
never okay rumor number three Kourtney
Kardashian approves of Charlie dating
her stepson Landon Barker
um no I hope it's true I think so hmm I
think she likes you yeah yeah Landon's
families have you met the barkers
I have get it Landon's family is amazing
you know he's a he's a great person and
they're all very nice to me he spends
all this time at our house yes and he
needs to start paying rent he's gonna be
there all the time he just brought a
gaming console over there which is weird
he's there all day every day okay next
rumor Charlie buys Tick Tock followers I
don't think you I personally did not buy
any of them I certainly did not because
I've heard that that the dad bought him
too no way oh wouldn't even know how to
do it that's your 20 year crazy to go
down that land like can you imagine her
taking the time out to figure out how to
buy it I mean I probably could figure it
out but do you think you would even want
to well now I kind of do yeah I'm out of
spite when people say that I buy Tick
Tock followers it makes me feel really
good because I didn't so it's like a pat
on the back to me like when someone says
like it looks like I got work done yes
and I'm like oh thank you
you think I have lip injections no way
like a lot no it's like the biggest
boost yes next rumor Dixie's real name
isn't Dixie I've never heard that rumor
before I've never heard that either what
would it be okay that's my real name her
passport so it's I can confirm if Dixie
was a boy she was gonna be Jackson and
Dixie named Charlie well no you guys are
gonna call me DJ oh well we're gonna
call her her name is Dixie Jane we're
gonna call her DJ but I think I my name
accumulates
the worst nicknames I think they're
funny dicks dick that's what everyone
calls me but if I had a daughter I would
name her Drew I love that name but wait
let's talk about Charlie's name that
wasn't the rumor that really sucks Dixie
named her and her I said oh it's gonna
be a girl would she be named her and she
said Cinderella and I was like
Cinderella is a star's name you would
have more followers if that was your
name okay understood I'll buy more
I wasn't listening
the let me in please Tick Tock sound is
actually Charlie Charlie explains the
sound context and reenacts oh I wasn't
supposed to read the print scene yes
that sound is actually me it was
recorded on someone's ring doorbell
footage outside of their room yes and I
did not know that it was going to be
posted I didn't know it was you for the
longest time
let me in please please we still talk
like that all the time so that is me I
heard the rumor that the reason why
Charlie gained followers is because he
is going to become president and it's
part of a whole master plan for her to
um I don't really know the plan I wish
we thought things out that way I don't
even know we're going to do
an hour after this rapid fire
parents what's something that Dixie and
I did as kids something funny oh you
drove your little Barbie car off of the
side off of a cliff uh well it wasn't a
cliff but it was like a very very it's a
cliff for a five-year-old what's the
most embarrassing story you've ever told
to one of our potential Partners
everything you guys tell people
everything yeah do we yeah but now I'm
like an embarrassment you're like oh
it's so cute but to me I'm like really
dead yeah I can't think of anything what
was the moment you were most proud of us
thank you so much Drew for having us and
we just played Drew's reality check
um we have the best time true and I'm
glad you got to know the truth
[Music]